on passe maintenant à l'actualité de la
terre avec l'édito de blacko es-sénia
bolshakova correspondante à moscou pour
france24 europe 1 que nous retrouverons
sur le plateau après le magnéto ce soir
nous poserons la question
poutine se prend-il pour staline
poutine a toujours été nostalgique de
l'urss à peine un style très mode il a
rétabli l'hymne national soviétique
choisit par ce pays dans 44 il a aussi
rendu le drapeau rouge à l'armée russe
et voilà qu'aujourd'hui comme au bon
vieux temps de la guerre froide ils
annexent la crimée d'où la question
faut-il se prend-il pour staline de
notre point de vue cette année des
adducteurs criminels comparables à
hitler selon les historiens entre le
moulin de la famine et les exécutants
facile staline aurait éliminé plus de 20
millions de personnes pourtant selon
picking staline n'a pas que des mauvais
côtés staline a vaincu les nazis staline
à industrialiser le pays staline est
parti à la conquête de l'espace et
surtout au temps de staline tout le
monde avait peur des russes en annexant
la crimée boutines confiante que la
russie reste les puissances militaires
redoutable vrai sur aujourd'hui il
aimerait bien de nouveau nous faire peur
selon les sondages réalisés aussi
l'intervention en crimée une bataille
gagnée dit % de popularité avec 70%
d'opinions favorables j'ai pour
comprendre les russes poutine n'est pas
un grand démocrate
d'accord mais je viens rendu sa fierté à
la russie difficile pour les russes de
regretter helsinki danser pourrait comme
un cochon pour les caméras du monde
entier autant delsinne l'empiré russe
réduisait comme peau de chagrin en
accordant l'indépendance à l'ukraine et
au pays basque aujourd'hui c'est le
contraire la russie a grandi à nouveau
son territoire poutine des phillies
occidentaux ils envoient des troupes en
prime et comme au temps où l'urss ont
envoyé des troupes en qui monte chez
costa qui met la question bien sûr c'est
jusqu'où ira-t-il face à une europe en
panne de croissance tiraillé par des
dissensions et abandonné par les
américains qui se tourne vers l'asie
poutine attend son heure il a le temps
avec lui puisqu'il a modifié la loi pour
pouvoir rester au pouvoir jusqu'en 2024
il aura alors passé 25 ans à la tête de
la russie presque aussi longtemps que
staline à la tête de l'urss
voilà c'est celle éviter de blacko mise
en image de julien grappa sénia
bolshakova bonsoir
cependant d'un moscou pour france 24 est
en plan et votre père a été
correspondant de la pravda à paris bien
des terminaux merci merci thierry alors
aujourd'hui en russie si je me trompe la
troïka les mines trosky staline incarne
la grandeur de la de la russie et là où
poutine est très malin c'est qu'il a
réuni finalement l'héritage des deux
seins l'héritage des dictateurs
communiste et qu'il a un peu comme la
succession il est dans la lignée de tous
ces gens là il s'est mis dans la lignée
mais en même temps il se revendique pas
comme un comme un héritier par exemple
le nom staline et jamais citer les nids
n'est jamais cité trotsky non plus
encore - trotsky d'ailleurs on parle de
la grandeur de l'urss on pare de la
grandeur du pays le peuple russe qui a
vaincu les nazis mais ces noms là sont
jamais évoqués donc c'est vrai que c'est
un petit peu c'est un petit peu délicat
on sait qu'il ya eu les purges
staliniennes la famine c'est pas un
personnage dont poutine se revendique
directement moi je trouve les
comparaisons un peu tiré par les cheveux
je sais pas comment poutine je pense
mais je sais que il a dit par exemple
que en parlant russe 1 que tous ceux qui
ne regrette pas l'union soviétique n'ont
pas de coeur mais que ceux qui veulent
la reconstituer n'ont pas de tête je
pense qu'il est en train d y laisser par
des procédés dont certains sont
critiquables donc sont condamnables même
enzo scifo le dissuader d'aller plus
loin il en train d'essayer de redonner
une sorte dignité de fierté ya un peuple
russe qui a connu un effondrement
épouvantable à la fin de l'union
soviétique en 91 et moi je pense qu'on a
bien de la chance s'il n'est pas sorti
du peuple russe contenu du traumatisme
qu'il a connue en 92-93 pire que poutine
en russie pour reprendre quelque chose
que vous dites dans votre livre au sujet
de la france il n'y a pas de haine de
soi que je veux dire les russes ils sont
très fiers déjà tout à fait juste parce
qu
il ya quelque chose de très présent chez
les russes et un complexe de supériorité
combiner un complexe d'infériorité serre
pendant toutes les années 90 les russes
se sont excusés dette russe issu d'un
pays qui s'est effondré avec toute cette
histoire qui était un peu bancal et
aujourd'hui c'est ce complexe de
supériorité qui est en train de regagner
du terrain et il regagne du terrain
d'une manière assez violente on voit
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui avec ce
patriotisme avec ce
militarisme et une ambiance très
particulière en ce moment à moscou qui
est vraiment oppressante ellouhoum ce
constat n'est très lourd des gens comme
moi élevés qui ont grandi en europe je
trouve ça particulièrement à vivre on
nous dit que le peuple russe est un
grand peuple un peuple fier qu'il faut
surtout et en même temps excusez moi que
c'est niamey le patriotisme de poutine
lui vaut 70 % d'opinions favorables
le côté je sais pas ce que je vais faire
de hollande lui vaut 25 % d'opinions
évidemment ça fait du bien quand pendant
vingt ans les gens ont vécu avec ce
complexe d'infériorité c'est peut-être
ça qui nous ferait en france compte tenu
de ce que disent et hubert védrine
ailleurs un bon pou ti est complètement
là
c'est pas la popularité qui donne la
valeur à un homme oui
oui mais ce que chez lui aux murs chez
lui à quelque chose quand même qui enfin
qui exalte la nation russe et obama il
exalte la nation américaine
et bien si on reproche jamais obama
d'exalter la nation américaine pas
exactement la même chose il n'a pas
envahi cuba obama lotina envahi la
crimée en deux secondes et personne n'a
rien dit non sérieusement poutine c'est
un grand leader ou ça un cinglé du point
de vue occidental évidemment il est tout
à fait sûrs rejetée nous agressent ils
nous provoquent qui se moque de nous il
faut absolument rien pour se rendre
aimable bon c'est un euphémisme mais il
faut avoir un jugement quand même dans
la durée moi il me semble qu'après la
fin de lurcy une désinvolture
occidentale pain pour la russie il était
tellement content que ça soit écroulait
les américains à certains moments
voulait élargir le temps alors que
c'était complètement injustifiée
notamment à l'ukraine que on a considéré
que ça comptait pour du beurre parce que
penser les russes n'ont qu'à une période
égale réaction à sa taille soit violente
qu'elle soit excessive c'est vrai
qu'elle posait problème qu'il faut
canaliser c'est évident mais on peut pas
faire l'impasse complètement sur la
russie et on peut pas avoir comme seule
politique de détester poutine tu as on
va pas vivre dans un monde où il ya pas
la russie il n'existe pas à quand les
européens disent l'ukraine va venir dans
l'europe pourquoi pas sauf que ça
signifie aussi que l'ukraine balai dans
l'otan demain si le mexique ou le canada
s'associe à la russie ça va emmerder
obama je vois pas pourquoi on ne
comprends pas que poutine n'a pas envie
que l'ukraine il veut pas que ce soit
dans le temps parce que l'otan c'est ses
ennemis pour aller dans votre sens à
oman à la fin du nom soviétique dans les
discussions entre les américains à
l'époque busch et jeff baker et les
européens dont le chancelier kohl il
était promis à gorbatchev qu'il y aurait
pas d'élargissement de l'otan c'est pas
dans un traité voisin teddy plusieurs
reprises après bush les présidents
américains suivants n'ont pas tenu
compte de sa tante poutine peut
considérer il exagère il peut considérer
que la promesse n'a pas été tenue alors
que c'est mia maintenant c'est à vous de
nous répondre jusqu'où va aller vladimir
parce que finalement la biélorussie il
ya un million de russes le kazakhstan il
ya 4 millions de russes donc il peut
dire aussi à un moment pourquoi pas la
biélorussie pourquoi pas le kazakhstan
lui veut reconstruire une sorte d' urss
non non communiste une grande union
douanière la biélorussie touchera pas
parce que il ya loukachenko ils sont
très amies kazakhstan ils sont en très
bons termes aussi en revanche tout ce
qui est tout et tous les petits
territoires transnistrie abkhazie c'est
tous ces terrains là qui risque
éventuellement d'organiser prochainement
des référendums pour demander à se
rattacher à la russie ça c'est possible
les provinces de l'est de l'ukraine
alors ça c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué à mon avis je pense que je
pense que le kremlin n'a pas envie de
s'avancer sur ce terrain là pour
l'instant à moins qu'ils aient une
provocation d'un côté comme de l'autre
et là ça peut là ça peut créer
effectivement peut-être une interview il
a dans ce cas-là hubert est ce qu on
bougera oui s'il ya sûrement rester la
situation actuelle elle sera condamnée
critique et ses draps mais il y aura des
sanctions des contre-mesures on va
s'enfermer dans une sorte non pas de
guerre ni de guerre froide mais de
guerre de tranchées souvent les
batteries au bout de quelques mois on va
dire non même pas spécialement les
français c'est surtout les les
entreprises allemandes qui sont éboulées
cydia il
ya 7000 entreprises allemandes en russie
il ya 700 entreprises françaises en
russie donc merkel pour elle c'est très
important donc au bout d'un moment on
dira que commandant soeur par rapport à
ça faut pas oublier que la posture
inflexible de baba elle lui coûte rien
ouais aucune conséquences économiques
pour lui et pour lui c'est une aubaine
de se montrer ferme
puisqu'il est considéré comme trop beau
donc il va avoir besoin de convaincre le
congrès à propos de l'iran donc on va
chercher un moment donné je pense une
porte de sortie dans trois quatre mois
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait attendait
quelqu'un qui veut mourir pour la cré
mais aujourd'hui qu'ils veulent et en
battre contre les russes on parle pas de
guerre on est surtout dans un monde
économique d'interdépendance
écoénergétiques donc il peut y avoir une
escalade en matière économique et
financière qu'ils aillent très fort très
loin là il va couper le gaz et puis
c'est tout oui mais il a coupé le gaz on
demande à quelqu'un aussi plus que sagna
dernière chose qu'est ce que les russes
vont de l'europe aujourd'hui ils se
disent qu'ils en ont marre
en fait d'être pris pour des moins que
rien et qu'ils aimeraient bien avoir un
petit peu plus de respect de la part des
européens sur les sanctions notamment
parce que moi j'avais j'avais interviewé
pas mal de gens dans la rue beaucoup de
gens nous disaient les sanctions c'est
pas grave le rouble qui tombe c'est pas
grave s'il faut aller faire la guerre on
ira des jeunes de 20 ans des jeunes
d'aider des jeunes gens de 20 21 22 qui
me disait ben moi s'il faut aller
combattre j'irai parce que ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est que la russie restaure
sa grandeur sa puissance sur la scène
internationale et qu'on récupère nos
territoires ça c'est des gens dans la
rue oui mais c'est lent c'est
significatif regarder dire que nous on
est mû par l'argent on pense que les
sanctions économiques sont très
importantes parce qu'on est adorateurs
du veau d'or s'enfler les ruchers encore
un pouvoir symbolique qui est au dessus
de l'argent c'est la grandeur de la
russie vous savez ce qu'elle dit surkov
ladislav sur koch qui a déconseillé de
poutine qu'on appelle sierre et kordian
le cardinal gris et dit la seule chose
qui m'intéresse aux etats unis c'est
jackson pollock allen ginsberg et tupac
et ça je peux y avoir accès sans avoir
de visa
donc en gros ils disent tous des
officiels aux gens de la rue les
sanctions ont senti que c'est dangereux
si c'est pour ça que madame merkel a
fait fuiter exprès l'impression qu'elle
a eu dans une décompensation cousine
elle a diminué dans un autre monde que
nous donc c'est quand même dans mais
c'est inquiétant c'est une sorte d'auto
excitation où le patriotisme qui je
crois est légitime dégénère en une sorte
de nationalisme excité il fallait donc
un danger quand même alors qu sénia
avant de nous quitter
je voudrais que vous ne fassiez plaisir
que les antilles via un petit poème en
russe une comptine d'enfants parce que
j'en lis jeanjean lee hanafi
rival audi et tramways est un coach
ne m'étais pas et après je me souviens
plus bravo
sénia merci d'avoir été avec nous et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu